[Music]
today on stick to football we're live
again from the NFL Scouting Combine in
Indianapolis and it's gonna be going
Matt bowling stopping by former
colleague of mine who's now at ESPN he
works on the NFL matchup show he coaches
high school football he's also the most
intense man I've ever hung out with so
we're having phone Matt Bowen talking
about a great article that he dropped on
Wednesday morning but guys the the story
that everyone is talking about as we sit
here at the combine sitting here on
radio Row is the tool time of my little
medical check which happened as physical
happen yesterday Ian Rapoport opened the
day basically by tweeting that the
medical check looked good once again
they're optimistic and for two of this
is now every step throughout this
process since the injury has been
positive we can go back to early January
when he met with the doctors in New York
they needed cleared for the draft the
medical check after that looked good now
the medical check here in Indianapolis
and this is a big one
this was the one where we needed to see
where the hip was at everything looks
good so all throughout the process - it
has been checking all the boxes looks
healthy now there is a debate happening
in indianapolis happening on twitter
with a healthy tua is he the best
quarterback in this draft or is it still
Joe Borough Heisman trophy-winning
quarterback threw 60 touchdowns this
year ran for five more an undefeated
season for the LSU national champions
to me there is no debate Joe Burrell was
my top quarterback in this class before
- it got hurt sitting in Tuscaloosa
Alabama for the LSU Alabama game that
was the moment that Joe burrow became
the top quarterback in this class for me
and really it was close but it was
definitive burrows ability to make plays
off platform we're gonna talk to Matt
bone about that his poise his field
vision his accuracy the way he plays
point guard for that offense is super
important now for - a the the talk here
at the combine you talk to everyone in
the NFL I have not found a person who
actually believes that - is a better
quarterback prospect than Joe burrow he
is a little bit smaller
he has significant injury history not
just the hip guys but - ankle injuries
as well we've talked a lot about that on
this show that's reason for concern you
also have a guy who is he's a little bit
over six foot tall and I know the NFL
has been a little more okay with that
with Kyler Murray and Baker Mayfield but
still a bit of a concern
and I think when you get down to it what
borough was able to do this year a
pro-style offense with Joe Brady coming
from the New Orleans Saints that
answered a lot of questions so you
talked to people in the NFL it's Joe
borough quarterback one tool talking
about a little quarterback too and then
Justin Herbert its quarterback three it
really feels solidified that that is the
order these quarterbacks will come off
the board now it was also in it actually
in a press conference Redskins head
coach Ron Rivera said they're gonna
bring in Joe burrow and to a tongue of
viola for official visits they own the
number two pick in the draft
they took Dwayne Haskins last year but
we have seen in the past where the
Arizona Cardinals last year they had
Josh Rosen it was the number ten pick
and the 2018 draft they still took
calamari from first overall last year in
the traded Josh Rosen so there is a
little bit of a precedent for a new
coach coming in and wanting to pick his
quarterback the Redskins they say
they're doing their due diligence excuse
me they're all options are on the table
guys to me the Redskins are gonna trap
chase young well they're being smart
about this they understand that a
healthy to it is a very very valuable
piece in this draft class so if you're
the Washington Redskins and you can
entice the Miami Dolphins to trade up if
you can entice the Detroit Lions to
maybe trade up you have to do it and I
think that's what we're seeing from head
coach Ron Rivera who's really running
the show there in Washington is a team
that is trying to drive up the value of
that number to pick in the draft
the quarterbacks here are all the buzz
when we talk about the rookies but it's
also the free agent class we have to
remember Tom Brady's for a chat dak
Prescott Phillip Rivers Jameis Winston
Teddy Bridgewater marks Mario to Ryan
Tannehill a lot of free agent
quarterbacks this year
one thing that I'm continuing to hear
and I know we've talked about this on
previous episodes of six football is
that the Indianapolis Colts seemed to be
the favorite at least to land Philip
Rivers in a movie would be a one or two
year deal
bring him bringing him in excuse me and
then I think there is a belief that they
could draft a quarterback to learn and
develop under River so that's this year
or next so I think those options are
definitely on the table for the Colts
who they do have Jacoby perset a little
bit expensive I know Melo talked about
that on the Friday show but they they
can fit this they have like 93 million
dollars in cap states they can make this
happen now again on the quarterbacks
this is something that has been
bothering me and I want to talk about
this
it hurts I don't know where this people
say oh there's speculation that okay
like is he gonna work out at other
positions why would he work out at other
positions he's never played another
position I also don't even think he's
athletic enough to talk about him
playing another position he's not you
know he's twitchy as a receiver he
doesn't have the burst to play that
position even if I were running back her
safety says he's a quarterback
quarterback that Alabama quarterback to
Oklahoma he's got every time he started
his team made the playoffs college
football I don't know why there was a
need to four there wasn't a need for
Jalen Hearst to say hey I'm not I'm not
working out other positions on a
quarterback it actually came out no NFL
team asked him to work out other
positions so I don't want to I don't
call out any of our fellow media members
and I honestly don't even know where
this started I don't know where this
originated that oh maybe Jalen Hertz is
gonna work out it in another position
he's not going to and I just don't I
don't know where this is coming from I
don't even know who is speculating about
Jalen Hertz working out at anything
other than quarterback night everyone
knows I think where I stand on him as a
developmental type quarterback but
someone that you can get on the field
right away still as a rookie in Wildcat
packages and a lot of the same things we
saw Jason Hill do and you're still
developing him as a quarterback while
letting him do those things on the field
right away as let him playing some goal
lines let him plan some short yardage
situations just find a way to get the
football in his hands as a thrower as a
runner I think Jalen Hertz can play
quarterback in the NFL now a player who
is going to be changing position or at
least doing drills in another position
here is chase Claypool and this is
something I tweeted about on Monday that
there's a lot of speculation that he was
going to be asked to move to Titan he
weighed in it almost 240 pounds 238
pounds so I think there's a good move
for him to show that not only is he you
know he's team first we knows about
chase Claypool he dominated on special
teams Notre Dame but that he's the kind
of guy that is willing to do whatever
the team needs him to do if that means
play Flex tight in he's gonna do it it
means play outside receiver he's gonna
do it I think clay pulling around three
is a really interesting option for teams
that need a red zone threat you need
somebody who can get big in the red zone
we've talked about the chiefs they need
that they need somebody who can get big
they have a little bit of a smaller
faster wide receiver core you need a
power forward you know there used to be
a saying you want to build your receiver
room like a basketball team well you got
your you got your point
I heard entirety kill you guys shooting
guard amiko Hardman you got a small
forward to Sammy Watkins now you need a
big body you need somebody who can get
in the red zone when things get tight
and make plays and that can be chase
Claypool for a team like Kansas City
again I think he's around three type
player let's take a break here from
Indianapolis we come back around Matt
Bowen stopping by to talk about his
article how he's gonna change the
combine for quarterbacks we're talking
about high school football we're talking
about our old days at be our together
and we back right after this so guys we
are joined by one of my favorite people
in the entire football industry one of
my best friends the industry Matt Bowen
who used to be with us a PR now and
killing it over at ESPN and we're lucky
to get you on we can do the show for
three years we finally get you on it so
thanks for stopping by here well I
appreciate it yeah anything for you you
know right a lot of Bud Lights have been
shared between the two of us you had a
really cool article come out this
morning Wednesday morning about how we
should re imagine the combine for
quarterbacks and it's it's a unique
article because it's not just you
pounded about 3,000 works there's a cool
video element somewhere and you can
speak to that but everything that went
into this article is it's really
impressive visually but first and
foremost the importance of changing this
event to where we're actually able to
evaluate the quarterbacks yeah and
you're starting to see that in general
just this year at the combine there's
gonna be new events now throwing a fade
route you know I don't think that tells
us enough obviously you know but I do I
give the league credit for thinking
outside the box a little bit and trying
some new things but we did it said okay
look at the quarterbacks right now the
modern quarterback trades Patrick
mahomes Russell Wilson Aaron Rodgers
still has a deck - Sean how they can get
outside the pocket and create when
things go south because things are going
to go south and once you see at the
combine is this static platform throws
yeah nothing's going south so what I did
is I went back and watched Josh Allen's
work out from the combine okay you tell
my guy who is 65 has all the athletic
traits in the world has the big arm has
the movement skills we don't see it you
see three and five-step drops throw a
quick out I know we get thrown quicker
that's why yeah here right always the
top ten punches seventy yards down the
field right you know saw that was with
Allen in his workout when they run the
deep post corner he's sitting there
waiting for I'm waiting and waiting okay
now I can unleash the ball but again we
know you can do that every quarterback
that comes here and you'll see it this
year
Burrell is not going to throw to is not
going to throw but love especially Eason
we look they have the tools they have
the trades that's why they're invited to
the NFL Combine so I said let's take
these quarterbacks that would just
discuss the pro guys and look at how
they move how they create and where that
came from was the high school game where
I coach you know I coached at IC
Catholic prep you knew yeah I know you
got to plug the program you got all them
so I coach at IC Catholic prep it's
outside Chicago in Elmhurst and how we
train our quarterbacks because look
that's where it starts yeah what do you
think patch of my home started at the
high school level right this is where
the young players start and how much
they have to move now granted and the
high school game right now more spread
base offense as I get it but yeah man if
you're playing in the two back one tight
end to wide receiver offense doesn't you
gonna be thrown from the pocket every
time yep you still get outside the
pocket still making plays on the move
and I think my home is a great example
obviously you can't teach some of the
stuff Patrick my home says you can't
take a 15 year old quarterback says I
want to make you patched my homes you're
not gonna do it no because he has
natural traits that you some some stuff
that cannot be taught but you can teach
them in terms of movement his creativity
his ability to feel pressure eject out
of that way ya think that I can I don't
just have to take a five step drop I
have the flexibility the freedom to move
around to throw across my body that's
Vegas won't ever do it that's the bigger
always told never throw across your body
well you see I'm a high school option
offense in 1994 go don't let you cross
your body and I ran inside and outside
beer and we had two plays it was buck
trap 25 waggle pass and 32 repass and I
remember times I wanted to throw across
my body my coaches would not be happy
with that right you're gonna bench but
you have to know okay look you look at
the King City offense I mean that's kind
of the standard right now Super Bowl
champions all the speed their butt off
it's a three by one sets you got a lot
of cross there's a lot of deep over outs
and a deep overs basic crosser it
extends a deeper down the for the wasp
play that one talks about yeah how many
times we've seen packed my home's role
does left throw back to his right and
throw a dime put heat on the football
okay so you have to be able to do those
things and the idea behind this was
let's start and I Greg whole club was a
quarterback coach who works in Chicago
company called next-level athletics and
I talked with Greg I said okay give me
your five best drills that show me how
you're trained
quarterback sitting outside look what
I'm saying with this this piece is we're
not getting rid of the 3 & 5 step drops
and throw the dick throw see I want to
see that stuff but I also want to take
it a step further so that's where it
started and then it ended up in
Hollywood okay so it was unique
experience for me I was out there in a
Hollywood set and we had former college
players who are now actors okay and the
quarterback we had was originally the
University of Washington finished his
career at Liberty University multiple
sport athlete played football baseball
in college and he had all the movement
traits so we we got to be able to
simulate that using you know almost like
a movie set type of experience to show
the game of football it turned out it
was really unique
well I'm not just reading it was cool to
see it in a movie right and so to have
that because you know some people learn
by watching something right by reading
and you you get a little bit of both in
that how like you were set my arm faint
and I want to ask you this you played
defensive back in the NFL for eight
years eight seven seven years I was
close I'll say next year and so back
then and even when I started scouting
and we were working together it was arm
strength wasn't like the end-all be-all
you know sigh oh you got to be accurate
first and I still believe that but I
think arm strength is becoming more
important because of guys like mahomes
Russell Wilson Aaron Rodgers the most
quarterbacks in the NFL right now
outside outside of deshaun Watson all
have strong arms
from your study of the league doesn't
seem like that trend is kind of
switching back oh I don't know be
switching back as I go back to my career
any guy like Drew Bledsoe
I mean when you played against drew and
this is when he was later in his career
in the Dallas Cowboys you had to get
back if you're playing covered - you
better not start at 15 better get 18
because he'll throw it over your head
and throw it on a line yeah so there's
different quarterbacks you have to adapt
to and then when Michael Vick gaming
League I'll see the you know the game
plan shifted when Michael Vick had that
arm talent to push the ball all three
levels especially went to the third
level he could take a shot yeah you know
so if a wide receiver you think he's got
it covered
ball still coming you can put it over
the top of your head so I think it's
coming back I think to a certain extent
is but you have a guy like Burrell - uh
Berlin - it don't have a lead arm to
know when you watch the film you know
this I'm not telling you something you
don't know there are more anticipatory
thrillers touch throwers accuracy ball
plays like a Drew Brees
yeah Aaron Andrew Luck was that way
yeah Kurt Warner I play with him that
career for the st. Louis Rams Kurt
Warner not have massive arms down
corners in the Hall thing because he
could put whatever you wanted to right
and he can understand we're supposed to
be an anticipate that window opening up
so some of the throws yeah there's some
throws that you saw from Josh Yale and
this year in Buffalo I I remember
looking at the film gaming as Miami the
game against the Giants second reaction
ability that's um also with this piece
the ability to make plays
some people say off schedule I say
second reaction yeah you're a quick game
we take away their first read what are
you gonna do ya can sit there right you
can't like I think Jared Goff had some
trouble with that you know they break it
away he could not get to his secondary
reads or he couldn't react off of the
script and I think that's why we see him
struggle yeah well Jared Goff we saw
this year in matchup show is when you
put heat on him force him to move off
the spot and force him to reset that's
where he struggles let's go back to the
year they went to the Super Bowl two
years ago when he's thrown on rhythm
then he is the anticipatory throw seven
or seven dice you up yeah so you have to
make a move right that's why again going
back to the idea behind this piece the
movement traits in my opinion are so
important and I think also offensive
line play has been down on the NFL and
you know this yeah I'm scouting
I mean offensive line play is down
that's why you're seeing more of this
why you see a more quick game that's why
defenses not to change the discussion
and then we were talking about Byron
Jones before the show why he's gonna be
so viable in free agency you need guys
play man coverage that's where the
league is more quick passing yeah more
RPO more in middle the field play action
but when teams take that away when you
have a Byron Jones when you draft
Jeffrey Okuda yeah and put him in your
lineup you gotta be on the move
got bill move off that spot and create
and keep plays alive and that goes right
into what I think makes Joe burrow so
special like you said he doesn't have
the best arm right but what blew me away
this year and I saw him play live four
times his ability to do that they play
breaks down or when he gets pressured
their offensive line was not as good as
some people thought when he would get
pressured his ability to move around
keep his eyes down the field and look
for look for Jamar chase going over the
top you know breaking off his route look
for you know Thaddeus Moss over the
middle Jefferson right or Jeff I mean
they were loaded but burrow as the point
guard of that offense was so special now
he was and it started
I know your Texas guy I'm sorry yeah
Texas scheme that third and seventh was
a third 17 yeah that if you want to
watch a quarterback you know we Matt and
I use terms all the time like a muddy
pocket someone that might not understand
what that means that means there's
bodies all around you it's chaos in that
situation Joe Burrell had nowhere to
move he found a place to climb in the
pocket slide in the pocket and throw a
dime to Jefferson on a deep over out
that sealed the gaming really kind of
catapulted his season for you know
making those place in that Texas game
but that's what he does you could turn
on the film every week there's not just
his movement outside the pockets is
moving inside the pocket like Tom Brady
Tom Brady and Bri don't have a mass you
just climb the pocket and make place we
were in Austin for that game and I
looked at Melo and said that kids going
first round yeah and that's when it
started that's when the climb for me
started with Baro - it was you know
first time I've seen him a second time
I've seen him in person with some
buddies Georgia the year before she's
like guys aren't supposed to do that
like that's you can't teach that
no I'm think about this and we we've run
into this discussion all the time
because you have guys that are from
non-power five schools or you know one
double-a whatever is going on what is
FCS yeah even d2 guys he said the level
of competition show bro
start him with Texas when they played
Auburn they played Alabama that played
Oklahoma that by Clemson played Florida
but yep give me a better line right
Georgia I mean yeah Georgia SEC champion
so were they DX seventy point and and he
produced against he's every one of them
yep so eventually got a look like which
I want here you're gonna look at the
traits first did the traits transition
to the NFL level yes they deal with Joe
Burrell again not does it have the Josh
Allen arm but again he just makes plays
Randy finally gonna say that you watch
him tell him you know what you can pull
the pin down you just say he's good he
makes plays I want I want him on my team
because I can develop him within my
offense in my system you think he's the
best quarterback in this class I do and
I understand the discussion with tool
but for me it's burrow it's just the
best way you can say there's nothing
against to it right you know it's too
late quarterback he's a very good
quarterback he's gonna be a top-ten
quarterback but for me it's burrow it
just there's the things we talk about
the traits the schedule he played this
year to production he had and doing it
every week
it's one thing to have a good cape look
I had a game in the NFL one time that
was good okay how many people remember
who was it one guess Tampa right so you
can have a good game right but to do it
every week in the SEC and then the couch
football playoff in the non-conference
vs Texas you'd get much better what I
always tease you about you're the guy
picked right after Tom Brady know right
before time right right right before 198
mister 198 that's amazing that's why I
tell people at holiday parties right
thank you have the best ice breaker ever
when you go to those high school you
know kids houses in Chicago that we open
with is you know I always guy picked
right for Tom Brady know a good eye
before but that is something that it'll
never leave that's what people talk
about right I would much rather say you
know that's Matt boning with the four
Pro Bowls it has two Super Bowl rays
look I'm not gonna lie but I yeah I mean
you had your seven years you were you
were a good player uh you went through
this combine a while ago 20 years how is
it exactly 20 now oh yeah yeah how
different is it not only different so
even you've been covering it for the
media for probably ten at least ten and
that's how long I've been here coming
here it's completely different I can't
imagine how different it was twenty
years ago
well 20 years ago we stayed in the hotel
which is the train station you know the
the crown plot Center or whatever yeah
that's we stayed and you would walk out
of a meeting or whatever there'd be like
five media members are yeah it's like
Peter King yeah the top guys yeah right
about the combine but not like this you
know a radio row you doing your podcast
here I mean it was like there was no JW
Marriot at the time right oh yeah that's
New Super Bowl and well one thing we ran
the old RCA Dome the Hoosier dome and a
lot of guys didn't run back then because
it was old astroturf and you ran in the
sideline you didn't run in the field who
ran the silent so it was real spongy
almost like a bounce to it yeah you say
it dig in yeah you can't dig in no clean
crap yeah so I went out and found like I
once like a running store and found like
some some racing flats I brought two
pairs one said spikes on them they said
no way you're wearing those so I had to
change my shoes and there were all the
flats and there you did the great play
brought up is
no please you can't dig in right and
that's why these times are so great now
because they're the real times you're
running on field turf you're getting a
sprinter stance that's a great surface
saw backed in like the top players I
remember from my class that just didn't
run they didn't work out here would you
run here everyone four four nine would
you run your pro day or did you run
again oh yes say okay so the reason I
ran in my pro day okay back then Iowa
had a bubble okay now they have brand
new in neuro facility under coach
Ference and we had a bubble so the year
before the summer there was like a
tornado north of i-80 and ripped the
bubble off it like blew down the street
so that turf sat out in the Sun all
summer baked oh it was concrete
it was concrete which is hard it was
hard man it was really hard like you
would explode off the turf so of course
Iran Iran and high four threes at home
it's not a real time though it's not a
real four three because I had the
tornado in the Sun to work with me but
look it's much easier to run at home
your strength coach warms you up yeah
you dress in your own locker room you
warm up with your teammates look if I'm
a quarterback I want to be here to
compete but I can't wait to get back to
my poet I throw to my own team off your
jobber I'll go three of that crew yeah
yeah and just even the DB drills you're
doing them with your teammates there's
this such a much more comfortable feel
and how that come on was different back
then we had the Cybex leg test okay
where he does anyone who's been to a gym
it's a leg extension you just do it
until you feel like you throw it lets me
see it how long can you do it for how
much power can you generate you did the
day before you ran Oh God so your legs
are gasps so you woke up next morning
you were sore you were very served by
the time I got done with the combine I
think it was a couple things one the
stress obviously the environment the
work you do the written test saying you
know talking with coaches and then
actually working out in the field then
finishing finishing that 60 yard shuttle
your gas fuel I could play the game you
feel like you're played the game your
body is basically shut down then you get
on a bus and go to the airport good bus
go to the airport you don't like go back
to your hotel room asleep and rest
you're gone you're gone that's why I'm
sure see what this [ __ ] looks like
because you're doing all that at night
now you brought you tweeted that last
week yeah or maybe earlier this week and
I thought it was a great tweet a great
example of if I'm the top agent right
now and I'm representing the chase Young
who's not running this week right
I want him to run in a new environment a
new testing environment that no one's
ever done before the times gonna be the
same because people say all the times
don't man they do man
they didn't why we doing it absolutely
matter yet are we doing here of course
they meant yeah
everything matters here everything
matters so I thought was a great tweet I
thought it was a great example of if the
combine well to see if it works
you know because look man if this
doesn't work and we don't know yet who's
gonna run run who's not and more guys
drop out he's got an issue it doesn't
matter what time you put it on TV if you
know have good players working out you
gotta have think is my and I'm I'm
surprised the league hasn't put a little
pressure no players that maybe they
maybe they have to say hey we need we
need Chaz young well look if I'm a fan I
want to drill barrel throat oh right
yeah that's what I want to see no
disrespect to Justin Herbert no no sir
I've got arms
but Joe Broz expected you know he's
young playing the college football
player I want to see these guys compete
and that's what is about it mean
everything here is a job interview
that's why I looked at as a player
that's a way to describe it to people
now because you're constantly monitor
and just how you how you talk how you
address what you do have a team not team
meals but at the meals yeah everyone
you're always being evaluated every day
is an interview here every step of the
process is an interview so it is a grind
and you're gonna like I said you've got
a run better at home all right but right
if I'm a scout I know that so I want to
see you running the most competitive
environment possible in this of what
this proofing you're probably adjusting
as an evaluator for guys of course well
it's a different time different surface
I actually already heard a story of one
player who walked into a meeting and
like wouldn't get off his phone this
problem that's like yeah you do that
English class that's a problem teachers
didn't get on you right you do that at
our football program and I see and
coming to team meeting with the phone
that's a problem all right so we do that
here what are you telling Peter
basically say don't draft me to that
team is no different than if you go into
an interview at IBM they know your phone
with the CEO of the company will not a
great look it's not a gribbler this is
all about professionalism that's all
what this is about show because you're
gonna be a professional athlete now ya
know that's fun man thank you for
stopping by man that was fun they're
pretty good to finally catch up ICC
football how many state championships
you guys want now and your time the
hurry
one three and then two in a row as I won
three in a row 2016 17 and 18 and then
last year we got beat by great Richard
Burton team give them credit they beat
us you're putting a lot of kids in the
college football programs though yeah I
think you know I think we're doing a
great job because you know the college
football landscape so deep you know you
got division one football one double ID
to the great d3 schools the Midwest yeah
also NAIA football because great
financial aid great opportunity for kids
to go play football and in front of
their education by getting that
financial aid so I've learned a lot
about the recruiting process especially
the lower levels and how good you know
people look at like d3 football
well d3 football don't know it was on
ESPN the national champion North Central
College which has been Naperville close
to us their villain oi those keep some
play man and they're big up front and
they get move there's good football at
all three levels it's great football
yeah and we are we have D to where we
live right like us be two powerhouses
it's still good football to kids to come
in the National Football League cowboy
huggers here ya know Ryan I don't even
know where that is they're gonna find
town man last year they have defensive
back from Dubuque cows you did see that
ball that's right so that's Division
three football though if you have talent
they'll find you but I tell our kids and
any kids in the area is if you won't
play football there's a there's a place
for you alright because playing college
football is a great experience get a
great education teammates for life
I think we've done a great job with that
and I see Kathryn awesome thank you
again follow this man at Matt Bowen 41
you won't regret it makes me smarter
every day on Twitter come on alright
thanks buddy
thank you thanks again Oregon now Boeing
for stopping by talking some in a
combine all the things that need changed
and it has actually been a little bit of
a quiet day here Wednesday they're doing
the bench press behind us right now the
wide receivers are over there benching
right now the running backs we talked to
the media so it's a little bit of a slow
day I want to close out the show today
with a couple draft on draft questions
we don't want to leave you guys at home
or those of you watching on YouTube we
don't wanna leave you out so let's start
here Scott Grimes asked should the
Eagles look to shop their first rounder
for a star receiver maybe obj or Stefon
Diggs now like Scott I actually think
it's a pretty good idea because you're
picking it number twenty one overall we
don't know what receiver is gonna be on
the board and I actually think you could
probably get some of these guys for less
than a first rounder so the idea of the
Eagles being aggressive to go get a top
reciever that really does intrigue me a
lot because again this is a huge need
for them I mean they I know they've said
the Al Shean is gonna be back but I
think this it it's still the biggest
area like it what's different about the
Eagles this year it was the injuries
what they couldn't get done from the
wide receiver position I think the only
issue you run into it this is how much
cap spaces this team have right now they
sit at about forty five million dollars
but you got to re-sign your own guys you
got save some money for rookies so I
think in theory this works you probably
want to look at if you can get a guy on
a rookie deal that would obviously
better be better but moving some draft
picks in order to get a wide receiver I
should love that for the Eagles and I'm
a little jealous that we hadn't thought
about it first so it's a killer question
Griff Cong asked looking at the success
of the NFL's current best pass rushers
couldn't you argue the AJ FNS that has
the better traits to succeed the Caleb
on chase on Evan s is power and move
seems like a better fit for the NFL so I
think with this question it goes down to
what type of defense are we running
because I think epinephelus to the same
position they almost play different
positions because Chaisson is gonna play
outside the tackle he's gonna use
quickness and bin to get to the
backfield Evan s is probably gonna play
mostly on the tackle so these are almost
like the kind of guys you would want to
compliment each other as pass rushers
and again I think goes to the type of
defense you're gonna run they're gonna
be schemes where you want chase on speed
and I think one thing to your point
here's the best pass rushers in the NFL
in my opinion right now are kind of the
quick guys who have power obviously but
they're able to win with that first step
quickness and I think you look at like
what Frank Clark did in the Super Bowl
what nick boasted did in the Super Bowl
those are your prototypical guys they're
both like 260 pounds they have power but
they have speed and that's what we're
looking like that's why chase young is
so special because that ability to
convert speed to power to beat people
both ways nick Bosa with that inside
move with the swim move but he can still
beat you and set you up on the outside
like that's what we're looking for and
that's why guys like Bosa
miles garret chase young Khalil Mack
that's why when those dudes do come
along
they're pretty special players and
pretty special prospects all right
Dominick the blind says if Tom Brady
goes to the Titans do you see them then
drafting a quarterback in the first
round so no I don't Dominic I think if
Tom Brady some how much of the Titans I
don't think they would draft a
quarterback I think they would see that
as
yeah we got two years to win a Super
Bowl let's do this you know we might
have to draft a right tackle to replace
Jack Conklin you might have to go with
the tight end because we know how much
Brady loves a tight in position and I
know they have some young guys there and
then you still have needs on defense at
you know at filling out that side of the
ball but I think the Titans have one of
the best rosters in football we'll see
what happens with Derek and arrange at
Conklin but I actually really liked that
roster Logan Ryan's also a free agent
who I think he had like a Pro Bowl year
and just got slep on so they have some
moves that they have to make to keep
some of this group together and you've
heard Mike Vrabel and Kenny Vaccaro on
this show talk about that you know how
that's gonna go for a we'll say to
yesterday it's unlikely they can keep
the top three four agents on this team
together so Brady goes there I think we
would see that 29th pick it used to fill
in some other spots you know whether it
be you know another pass rusher get a
big pass rusher opposite Harold Landry
or someone to help protect whoever the
quarterback it's gonna be next year but
I think I personally I think Brady's
back in New England next year I think he
is still a patriot I just can't see him
leaving maybe I'm just living in like a
biased world right now Tyler Ward and
asked us guys ranked Josh island the
quarterback Jordan Love and Jacob Eason
in terms of pre-draft grades and in
terms of ceilings so for me will be Josh
Allen I am and was it Josh Allen fan and
I would actually put it in that order
Josh I enjoyed and loved Jacob Eason I
think with Jacob Eason my biggest
concerns are decision-making and the way
that he struggled against good defenses
with Jordan love I mean it's also
decision-making to be honest guy through
70 picks this past year but it's you
know getting him with better levels
competition around him a good offensive
line and good receivers getting him back
to what he was in 2018 under Matt wells
I think that's the key and when we talk
about prospects I mean it's all about
and I'm glad he use the term ceilings it
is all about that I mean this is like
evaluating a company and saying I want
to buy stock in that company because I
think they're going places and that's
what we're doing prospects is you have
all the keys you have the
characteristics to be really good but
there's always an unknown factor and so
I think with each each of these guys you
know especially Jordan Love and Jacob
Eason we've never seen him play in the
NFL there's always a bust factor with
those guys I think Jordan Love and Jacob
Eason at the quarterback spot like those
are the two guys where if you're
drafting them in the first round you're
a little bit worried about that bus
factor when it comes to
the way that they play quarterback there
was a little bit reckless neither player
has been like fantastic in college so
those are the things that you worry
about I mean this isn't a Patrick
mahomes situation where we're
overthinking a guy who was fantastic in
college had no one around him didn't win
a ton of ballgames but you knew his
traits were amazing and we all over
thought it because he'd never taken a
snap from center and he played in cliff
Keating Sperrys Texas Tech offense which
is basically the NFL now let's do one
more question here from our guy Patrick
Chamberlain how realistic of a scenario
is it the possibility of the Jags
trading both their first rounders that's
number nine and number twenty to move up
to pick three or four to draft Jeff
Okuda as the Jalen Ramsey replacement
Pat I don't think it's crazy but I think
it would be reckless to do that because
in irresponsible to trade nine and
twenty for a corner it's a lot for a
corner and I like Jeff hakuna that's a
lot for a corner I don't think you trade
that you trade that much for a
quarterback or late Laremy Tunsil you
don't read that much for a corner so I
think more likely you know we would see
them at nine look at guys like CJ
Henderson see where they valuate him at
twenty whoever your third corner in this
class is there's a lot of conversation
about that who that who is the third
corner you know after a CUDA and I think
even for some people it's okay after CJ
Henderson for me it's Jeff Gladney at
twenty he'd be a little bit of a reach
so I think for Jacksonville the good
news is when it comes back around to
them you know they have pick nine in
that pick 20 when it comes back around
what can they get in this class at 42
can you get Christian folt in there can
you get Stanford Samuels there there's
make corners in round two that'd be good
players at 42 I mean he'll jaylen
Johnson might be there AJ Tyrell might
be there so there's good corners that
could be there on top of Christian
Fulton so I think 42 might be your sweet
spot if your Jags fan looking for that
corner spot to replace Jalen Ramsey all
right guys that is our show our last
show from India without Connor Connor
we'll be here tomorrow Mel will be here
Friday of course we have our event
Saturday two o'clock at Judy Brewing
Company it's free it's open to the
public she's gotta be 21 to come in Joey
Molinaro is gonna join us we're gonna be
doing all kinds of draft talk I know
he's gonna be doing impersonations it's
gonna be fantastic I actually had a
chance to meet him earlier this week I'm
really excited did sit down and hang out
with him so if you're in the indie area
if you're here covering the combine
please come say hi it's gonna be a good
time so we'll see you guys Saturday at 2
o'clock
thanks again at Matt Bowen for the
awesome
interview and we'll talk to you guys
tomorrow